today on our show Ben Affleck has left
the director's chair of the Batman and
analysis by me and Mark Barnard and
today on Batman on Batman
[Music]
welcome to fat man on Batman Kevin Smith
I'm rock Bernardo okay man in the
special report is right breaking news
that's two nights ago Ben Affleck who
plays the Batman actor director Ben
Affleck world famous Ben Affleck guy I
once knew Ben Affleck guy was going on
six of my movies many more Ben Affleck
was gonna direct the Batman he was and
remember we talked about like it was a
story where he's like I have two scripts
not right below us and I think I floated
then I was like does he do it yeah why
did he do it he needed does he what's
the what's the upside news the other
night broke but then it officially
stepped out of the directing chair for
Batman the Batman mmm it's still his
script with Jeff Jones and he says he's
looking for new director he has say and
who gets me the director and stuff like
that Warner Brothers loves him over
there so you know a huge turn of events
because everybody was like oh man I
gotta d'arnot's gonna make [ __ ] I'm
Batman I remember being a Comic Con
where they brought him out with the
other directors of the DC's and the
architect of the DC Universe and they
were like well got some money look at
that we're spending and now half of
those directors of the DC Universe of
junk alley patty Jenkins and Zack Snyder
and still Sandin man James Wan but I was
David Ayer on that stage and Memphis was
let me pull it up and he's involved
Gotham girl yes okay so what do we know
not much just that he's not going to do
it anymore and they want other someone
else of course is going to do it too
trying to get back on a schedule let's
talk about why why would this happen I
don't know I haven't spoken them in
years but here's my take on okay here's
my hot take offer a theorem what's the
upshot seriously everybody wants that to
be the greatest Batman movie ever made
and you know many cases maybe greatest
Batman movie ever made has been made
call it the Dark Knight pretty wonderful
films that's your bar for a Batman
standalone
Chris Nolan couldn't even measure up to
himself with the Dark Knight Rises I
liked it but wasn't big blood received
nearly as well [ __ ] let's be honest like
that Joker portrayal is 40 ages [ __ ]
beyond brilliant [ __ ] so the tall order
man so maybe he's the kind of guy who's
just like why why bother like why am I
gonna step up to the plate no matter
what I do
people are gonna [ __ ] I can never be
same [ __ ] The Dark Knight I'm [ __ ]
but if I'm just acting in it not my
fault my name is Paul between y'all I'm
just a bat that's it the guy or girl
tells me what to do and go and so you
got to be put the movie talk to these
[ __ ] that's easier that's an
easier life you don't have to sit there
and take the slings and arrows he got
beat up over BBS like he did he he
didn't get beat up I got beat up
oh he got beat the [ __ ] yeah but like he
was also with Stanley he was taking in
some of that damage but not I mean
honestly most of those reviews like you
you have to dig deep to find a review
that was like [ __ ] he sucked like
everyone was like he's great he's like
the best part of this movie go figure
the part we were most worried about is
the part that turned out great so it
feels like that's the unassailable
element right now totally but laymen
even like in all of his [ __ ] that BBS
took and there was a lot to attack you
for apparently that was the one thing
where most people were like a man at
least that happened yeah but I mean he
was still part of that storm like he was
still what we saw on the press junket
sad sad act Med flick you know like he's
still internalized enough of me people
don't like this I thought it was good
but people don't like it why is it go
hard if I'm him I'm just like a man like
truck and I'm a dad I showed up I did my
job
you know like that man right yeah and
like me doing my job forget the be
Superman just called Batman world good
yeah but you know he's also in the
perspective of I've got all of these
[ __ ] chips do I push them all in the
middle knowing I have all these chips or
go just go home with all these [ __ ]
chips he's still got a stellar cinematic
track record as a director Gone Baby
Gone wonderful movie the town is
a movie that earned our respect and Luke
and our go and loot and Oscar's lived by
night with Valenti had just recently
didn't work out so well which I'm sure
he will not talk about very much not
necessarily his yogas but he definitely
you know being nobody's going like yeah
20 guys your movies are bad quietly
though like swept under the rug
yeah like you didn't hear any [ __ ]
fallout even getting any Gigli for it or
anything like that yeah but maybe he's
feeling a little like ah [ __ ] it's like
you know I can't maybe I should step out
for a little bit reorganize whatever
[ __ ] guys are going to yeah [ __ ]
miraculous pace ever since he got back
behind the camera on the on Gombe begun
so you know maybe he just wants to like
change lanes the man who was in changing
Lane and slow it down to speed words
like hey like you know I don't need to
do everything I'm just like I've let
other people do stuff I'll just be
standing here in the dark suit talking
in a gravelly voice blah blah blah blah
blah and you know one of the things we
know about actors having worked with a
fair number of them at the interview to
say never them hmm
they like being liked yeah you know like
you don't you don't subject' yourself to
that much rejection trying to be an
actor you don't endure watching yourself
blown up on a screen 70 feet tall unless
you like people liking you unless you
like the adoration of it hmm and the the
window of opportunity for massive
success for the Batman movie you know
like can you make a better Batman movie
there's no one it's possible sure
everyone will one day everybody will one
day their likelihood the odds of it
being this movie you know also possible
God grant I mean I had to read the
script but I mean it's got a good
pedigree between then and talking geoff
johns right so there's there's more of a
chance to not be overwhelmingly loved
then we live a chance to you succeed
with greater well you got to ask
yourself what's the dream yeah what's
the dream ever since you were a kid or
an actor did you dream about directing
Batman or dreams about being Batman
because if he dreamt about being Batman
your dream came true you all got your
Batman and people if I could go like
holy [ __ ] it's Batman the directing
thing like he knows like his bread
butter has grown up adult fare and stuff
like that so you know maybe it's just
easier for him to be like look let's
give your lacked in this thing I just
want to act like that man I want to
direct that yeah and there's also the
fact that Warner Brothers I'm sure one
thing the money one would assume to get
from a giant Batman movie when you spend
the kind of money their custom to
spending on dry movies like this yeah
hundred fifty million two hundred
million dollars yeah on a Batman movie
yeah
and it's entirely possible if not may
preferable to make this movie smaller
mm-hmm
tell them your story so your theory I
mean answer here is here is the core of
what makes a Batman movie bad memories
film noir right it's detective stories
of gumshoes that Sam Spade it's its clue
trails all that shit's procedural and it
comes from it is I am kicking the [ __ ]
out of you with no [ __ ] any problem
doing it it's it's you know exercising
physical capacity at its highest level
those things are historically cheap to
do torture some are like like a Maltese
Falcon [ __ ] like you see movies like
you're Red Rock and brick from ryan
johnson you can make a film or detective
story for almost nothing
yeah you can make a kung fu movie for
almost nothing as the Shah brothers
shoulder from China for 30 years why do
you need to spend $100 on a movie
defusing those two things so how much
would you spend on 30 perhaps brilliant
like just video here's 39 go make a
Batman movie 30 money see what that
would look like Tim Burton didn't even
make a Batman movie 30 million videos 40
yeah but he's right he's right baby
but he's absolutely right and if 30
million dollars you can make it read at
all sir I would like to buy a ticket for
your back what's your picture the smart
play right there and guess what here
head your bets
do that one mm-hm for 30 35 or whatever
yeah over here
do another one 400 hundred fifty this
character can sustain multiple [ __ ]
interpretations so just keep making a
Batman movie star wars Batman that's
what I [ __ ] every year there's an
Batman moving you could have like you
know Justice League's and flashes
whatever stalked the world Wonder
Woman's up the wazoo in between but
every year every May or every [ __ ]
Christmas a Batman movie get on that
schedule and pull them around everybody
wore amount to every [ __ ] denominator
you know what they do in the comics of
Batman he's not put in a special little
box and only taken out once every
[ __ ] more years he works like a
[ __ ] two-dollar trick I got 96 titles
in his name and he's [ __ ] co-star and
another hundred thousand just [ __ ]
make them make a bunch make that one
make a ridiculously expensive one make
one in space [ __ ] big ones like make
Justice League dark every year there
needs to be a Batman movie and he's got
the [ __ ] Rose Gallery unlike any
other character in comics to sustain
that like you don't get to the bottom of
that barrel until you're nine movies in
before you like calendar man sure you're
kidding me
we'll be dead before they're like we've
never done condiment King let's do it
you know like that it's such a deep
[ __ ] well a bad guy that's if you
even decide to use a bad guy yeah in the
world of 35 million you get away with
like you know [ __ ] now what was our
picture they did the cartoon mask of the
Phantom like he was creating that's it a
bad guy so Joker was in a tube or still
so anyways [ __ ] you know that that's
mine now that's why I run a studio
because people like you're out of your
[ __ ] mind
but in a Batman consumer and I could
look at me I could look at me I consume
a lot of Batman I would consume once a
year happily just like I'm ready I'm
lining up for Star Wars I'm lining up
now for the next Star Wars and the hand
solo movie and the [ __ ] keep in
common so one Batman movie a year and I
would like not for nothing but once
Gotham is off the air you get Batman
back on TV I would black mirror that
[ __ ] I would just find a bunch of
amazing directors you're making me hard
do a bunch of standalone stories yes
that's all I want tales of the Batman
tells of the Dark Knight on television
normalize this [ __ ] man make in
like the network news where you're like
oh it's always on there's always who's
on always the Batman like Law & Order I
should be able to turn
my TV exactly jungkook um there's the
[ __ ] give him the Dick Wolf Gotham
central Gotham fire Gotham [ __ ]
lawyer I saw Star Wars and I'm like
that's just law and order in Chicago
isn't it pretty much oh my god give it
to Dick Wolf Man and [ __ ] churn out
money for you have so many different
franchises and [ __ ] Batman is there
[ __ ] it's there Mickey Mouse there
Kermit he needs to be working constantly
yes
constantly constantly now uh oddly
enough because I do this show because
I've been known to direct enlightening
because I've made recently for CW
superhero shows and because I've got
past connection to Ben Affleck my
Twitter lit up with a bunch of people
gone why don't you direct it and some
people were legit it wasn't just like
you know a bunch of Twitter eggs gone
you drank it ha ha ha there were some
little there's guy from The Wall Street
Journal is like hey you know you should
be should be getting in touch with Kevin
Smith and I tweeted like you guys are
very very very I'm very flattered but
number one there's three reasons this
would never happen number one
I haven't spoken half like in years
number two I made yield oohs there's a
number three common [ __ ] set I
thought it was adorable though and
continue to like today's yeah rub me
into some that too like you should write
it like well again I'm all for it that
is I would totally do that if somebody
wanted me to do that I know that's the
thing everyone's just like today I'm
reading a lot of tweets going come on
you just directed them right you act
like I'm a [ __ ] choice in this yes I
will put out like a [ __ ] so if
somebody brings me to the dance
yeah that's never gonna [ __ ] happen I
ain't getting that call and some people
like well you should call him or you
should reach out to don't work like that
it doesn't work like that they want to
hedge their [ __ ] bets with somebody
who's dealt with big budgets and [ __ ]
has had success in the past and there's
a science to that [ __ ] to the air up
there said that don't include people
like me now who would I put baller who
is that look I'm you're gonna hear this
from me from for me from now until the
end of time
Jamilah give him everything he didn't
get better pool and he's not doing
Deadpool now you want to really [ __ ]
send a [ __ ] you to the X people used to
work with [ __ ] bagman
holy [ __ ] that's the only step up from
Deadpool it's [ __ ] Batman right give
it to Tim Miller I think he could do
anything or another Miller yes and yes
yes
George Miller right oh my god how about
bolt
come on a co-direct what did Miller's a
couple Miller's making the Batman if we
get a Miller's Crossing in Gotham
failure in the show nothing is going to
be better than that that's right a
Miller's Crossing would [ __ ] there
then you've got a real chance at making
them better moving than the other side
it was crossing at crime in alley oh
right there [ __ ] those are two names
I'd like to see especially in a world
where they got a script yeah been
scrapped Geoff Johns script they're
using that script everybody's got the
dick card for it Tim Miller George
Miller or Miller's Crossing is my pick
about you uh I kind of like ryan johnson
for this oh he just got off a [ __ ]
star we just got off the [ __ ] Star
Wars but got off of Star Wars like he's
done in the Star Wars universe he's got
experience telling film noir stories
brick brick he's got experience with a
budget and science fiction little her
livers amazing little birds are amazing
movie which is basically Akira in the
future you know super-powered young kid
who's being held temp what are the
rocker yeah tell you some man loopers
like Akira is as impenetrable as a
[ __ ] teen girl conversation looper is
very easy to understand I don't know if
those two are [ __ ] equal but you know
it's a movie about you know let's go to
Japan they go first ban at one point but
it's about this kid who's got this
amazing power that doesn't matter
control who's wanted by the government
and who loses control by the end of that
movie hmm
all right got about that yeah you also
forget about the Rainmaker yeah every
little bit when I think a looper is
Bruce Willis shoot himself over and over
again is like more of that yay I'll pay
to see that again but yeah I think
hidden again now
with Star Wars under his belt he's got
big budget also he's got working with a
franchise you've got to helping to
manage the custodian as I kind of rise
in gold me sold me [ __ ] I would watch
the [ __ ] up rip rip leave Ronnie
medic you're absolutely right Ryan just
good job to get you to up um
Dennis you New Guinea you know gotta get
Danny bill new [ __ ] shot cos I love
the rival nothing else he's done it bad
exactly so so far so good in my book who
else um Paul Verhoeven what movie did he
have this year that Isabel Hooper yes
well L that was good that was is ah well
you're talking about the man who did
Robocop he's talking about the man who
did sorry this looks obnoxious but I got
an itch in my nose
as I calculated cuz I don't do coke
either get it it's booger related sorry
I guess get in there move uh gets when I
gold um Paul Verhoeven also did the bug
movie yes Starship Troopers come on I
also did Total Recall job to mom get
your mom I mean I think like a he's a
visual stylist I call it an underdog
choice which I rendered them but he's
also like he's a satirist and there's
something inherently insane about the
Batman story I'd like to see that you
know and I feel like there's there's a
take on that to be had yeah I advise
Omega like that
although just say that loud did was
showgirls showgirl and Basic Instinct
that's right spent some time in the
crotch mine and also yeah could you
imagine like I'd give Paul Verhoeven
r-rated Bethan yes like just him busting
into a strip club
what happened in a barrel the movie I
like when I like taken to that dance
scene [ __ ] place again singer that's
my buddy
alright that's that's a dark horse
candidate rocker cannon
Michael sapota who directed the Battle
of the bastards episode of Game of
Thrones whoo yeah alright [ __ ] done
and done that was complicated episode
yeah balance a lot of different
storylines he's done a few drones
he's one of they're like we're bringing
this dude in for the big deal good pull
good for like a he understands how to
work with a budget not the sexy choice
but after that movie his name would be
synonymous with the
choice where the sexy choice and he's
done his time in the [ __ ] field in
his show real it's [ __ ] dynamite
absolutely I mean Michelle Maclaren came
out of Game of Thrones and Breaking Bad
Alan Taylor who did Jen ysus came out of
Game of Thrones Chen Jien wife I think
that I think that dude has a sort of
affinity for genre storytelling and can
actually muscle it okay so that action
will [ __ ] kill I like it what else
you got um you would mention Lexi
Alexander our yeah right I wasn't even
the first I saw somebody on online was
like either Kevin or Lexi and I think
there's a good lucky Alexander but I was
like right away that punisher movie she
did is great she thought I heard the CW
and heroine Supergirl um yeah Lexi
Alexander is [ __ ] hot director I mean
holosuite hot because she's a girl
[ __ ] knows how to shoot how to shoot
action like a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] and
she's a martial artist like legit
[ __ ] like crushing bones that what
there you go
oh my god somebody who actually like
most of the directors on the Kim you did
Chris Nolan can throw a [ __ ] POG Wow
no no Amanda Lexi oh yeah nor she done
[ __ ] she would actually fly off the
wall and show you how to hammerhead
somebody with your fish alright she
thought is I put her atop of Lisbon as
an island choice I would walk the [ __ ]
out of it I would watch the [ __ ] Lexi
Alexander the Batman as a man and a
woman directing the Batman yeah my
fingers there's some tension there and
she also like yeah and it's because it's
not just like also find the heart and
Batman [ __ ] that she's actually
directing nothing yeah that [ __ ]
party movie I defy you to [ __ ] watch it
moving tell me they're in a comic book
movies yeah it's wonderful I didn't
never got enough credit never does
there's a number guy in waste even
receives and I guess Ray Stevens oh yes
we call it look at it look at it um yeah
man [ __ ] I say Lexi Alexander's good
call that's a good call and my last on
my list is is Mary Hammond of director
of American Psycho American Psycho like
I feel like getting at the insanity of a
person who has gotta wear two faces yeah
who's got to be both a corporate person
and [ __ ] corporate dude on the
streets
vigilante madman on the streets yeah you
know like I'm bad movies [ __ ] bloody
and pulpy is [ __ ] like I think there's
there's a way into the madness of Bruce
Wayne
the inherent eye problems and wasn't
like American Psycho referenced as one
of the touch points for why he became
Batman like I like to do allottee or
some yeah I think so like you know that
that's movie that I would watch but I
agree we're gonna go for an old
directors out old like Mary's older son
but somebody who's your sighting old
work mmm-hmm let's give it to Jonathan
Demme II literally Lounge the Lambs
makes the Batman that would be bad at
you know what I'm saying Islands land is
a Batman movie without the [ __ ] cape
of gal and animal Lecter is the [ __ ]
Joker more subdued like Jonathan Demi
now just [ __ ] close-ups people looking
right down the barrel and [ __ ] like that
mmm-hmm the we could dream getting could
dream the dude who directed the Wade
Gareth Evans editing his name is that's
[ __ ] good call I would watch that
[ __ ] all day long give him a Batman
movie [ __ ] yeah yeah oh yeah all that
action all about that train will be like
dude train to Busan yeah okay I don't
know Korean dudes I gonna know I mean it
movies great there's it'd be good for
this you were gonna show with a Boojum
oh I think you directed snowpiercer yeah
some people's about it it's a [ __ ]
badass movie pretty [ __ ] phenomenal
alright look at that we didn't lick
giant [ __ ] list yeah like like we
don't refuse people but Warner Brothers
call us we'll put you in touch with them
somehow yeah call the representatives
that's a impressive [ __ ] list right
there you know all people you could call
tomorrow
all of which you would like you know on
Batman okay I got a take
they've all got takes but you know what
I still say it's not too late for bender
do it spender make the movie makes up
Batman make up Batman don't worry about
[ __ ] what people have to say dude
guess what it'll never be that as bad as
[ __ ] Batman or Robin
mhm just accept it if you make it it'll
never be a letter makes it there were
gonna be as bad as batman robin no
probably never going to be as good as
The Dark Knight and it will never be the
last Batman movie exactly exactly
you can't kill this [ __ ] Garrity no
can't kill the franchise so [ __ ] in here
man like I know it works for me and my
career don't work as good as his but
light a [ __ ] fatty kick back and be
like [ __ ] it let's do the
damn before could happen it will make a
bungle and go into production right
there the top of that [ __ ] over our
knees go direct that moment you could do
it you can't do it but if not we came up
with a bug our lives right there
of course I'm not saying no if anyone
wants to also call him
don't call me also call me I would up
call me to watch
hey don't everyone out there going you
should direct this [ __ ] this get me in
the [ __ ] no [ __ ] make I'd
love to be a penguin probably give it
like that I'll go over simple [ __ ] but
ideally I'll take a punch in the face
you know that I'm like a shady lawyer
get somebody auctioned got off and [ __ ]
rotters me up and whatnot
orderly yeah welcome to yourself at a
Batman movie um there's gonna be a movie
called the Batman someone's gonna direct
it we don't know who it is just yet and
it's gonna be in it Ben's gonna still be
in it Lexi Alexander jump Johnny yeah
that's a good call um that yeah Adam
makes all the siding yeah that would
make all the sense and it's an angle
yeah it's a one more angle spell that
movie from because you watch the on the
character the people alike are you
booking Batman but if you were like you
ain't see Batman with a woman in charge
[ __ ] people would be very
curious about that also a woman who will
give you like John wick meets Gotham
City yes
like she would pull them out and put a
watch that Punisher movie of hers you
doubt what I'm saying there's a [ __ ]
iMovie lit yes because the kid says the
lingo I'm not fit children
lit like literature it's lit AF okay but
calm your fears folks that the Batman is
coming no worries there it's gonna be
here and Ben Affleck didn't play any
wrote the script so it's all good not
not going to be about that yeah and now
it's gonna be somebody else regnant
might be George Miller yeah we're all
you [ __ ] madman fans he's not a
[ __ ] pac-man
original directing madman would be
interesting Mad Max fans man truckin
Magnum handle in the Batman he almost
did yet with the Justice League movie
lows that was aborted during the writers
strike years ago so
you know what right now my top ticks mmm
Lexi and George yeah both excellent
reasons for going with them and stuff
George though you know there's a
sentimental kind of like come on he
almost did Justice League man like give
him like he's got a strip yeah let's go
and it's not like you know Mad Max movie
were to like we're gonna shoot this in
the [ __ ] they took ten years there
you know they got a nobility a set you
experiment they will buy you Detroit if
you want it to make a Gotham saying you
ain't kidding man you just sit there and
after every take you said Affleck
that'll do Pig you treated like babe
[ __ ] I hope it I hope it's one
of those too many people on the list
Agrippa's look Lexi and you're both both
of them they would ride shiny chrome you
ain't cater straight into Baja indeed
they live they die they livin it in
there it is I love the show for Batman
I'm Batman Kevin I am mark barnard
turning turning turning kids go back to
the next episode we'll talk more [ __ ]
same bat-time same bat-channel spawn
kiss car more youtube.com slash Kevin
Smith no words down there Nate huh
[Music]
you